all right it is time for monday night
football almost so we're giving you a
head start on your game night dinner
plans how about some loaded gourmet
fries any style there's no better man to
help us out with that than mr fry's las
vegas himself let's welcome steve
phillips franchise owner of mr freisman
how you doing i'm good how you doing
nice to see you again um you know two la
kids in vegas we love to see it so show
us how it's done
let's let's talk about what you do all
right so basically we'll start off with
the fries as your base then we'll take
a scoop of cheese okay okay
and then so one of our customer
favorites is the lemon garlic crab
shrimp that sounds cool so we'll start
off with your sauce okay we'll take it
top to bottom because you're all sauced
up and we just layer everything up and
so what what are the what makes these
sauces special are they house made are
they
like the regular classic ones that
people love
secret
oh oh
so yeah excuse me so while you do that
i'm gonna i'm gonna try doing my own
okay so we can start drawing on a honey
garlic shrimp and steak
okay so like i said so you'll take the
cheese so you can start cheesing okay
and then this one right here that's your
honey garlic and then your sauce that
bad boy up so when people come into
order what's the process like because
it's like a it's like casual fast casual
food right yeah
for the most part so what they'll do
like so we have all our customer
favorites right now we're making some of
our customer favorites and if they don't
like any of those they could build their
own
so you really like the master of your
own destiny like the the sky is the
limit i've seen people pack on like nine
different like we have nine sauces i've
seen people pack all nine sauces on and
i've seen people pack on like four or
five meats it's crazy that's crazy so
it's a fun food like kids love it yeah
especially like the younger crowd they
like they love it love it okay and for
for me i know this is great for sports
and game nights but also if you have a
long night in vegas or if you're
studying you're located near unlv right
correct so let's talk about your
locations so i'm on flamingo and
maryland
uh right across from right across from
the school basically okay uh we have
another location that's uh owned by one
of my friends from l.a
also they're in north vegas okay good to
know so you're kind of across the valley
then yeah and then we have a franchise
popping up in henderson uh me and my
partner duane we signed for a location
in summerlin so that should be up
between
six to six months to a year so we're
moving around we got a total of 11
franchises right now wow
that are open 33 sold oh my gosh
congratulations congratulations okay i
have let's show off these plates you
hold yours up
i went a little what's this that's the
parsley is like i want a little ham on
the
i don't i don't know this is not no no i
don't know about this where can people
find out more information their website
uh mrfriesman.com
misterfries.com okay i'm gonna try one
though got to
like this is our number one seller that
and then the honey garlic crab the
shrimp oh my gosh the flavor jc i'm
saying to you i'll be there for the
opening of the summerlin store i will be
there for that one